hi everyone if you're watching this you
probably saw that Ubisoft just revealed
Ghost Recon break point in their
livestream that is the sequel to 2017 s
Ghost Recon wildlands I'm Mike I got the
chance to check out the game and play
like 15 minutes of it recently Alex from
Giant Bomb our friends over at another
find CBS eye property is joining us
hello
there's some things I liked about this
preview there's some things I did not at
all
it's obviously we're playing like in an
alpha stage so take it as you will buy a
dress let's start off with what's
exciting I guess so I actually like
liked wild lands for what it is I did I
didn't love it
I was lukewarm on many aspects of it but
I enjoyed that they kind of are taking
especially because it came out kind of
alongside the division so it gave me
that more tactical stealth five that I
was looking for although it did have
those like GTA kind of all-out aspects
with vehicle combat whatnot but I do
feel as if a lot of break point is them
trying to answer criticisms of wild
lands for better or worse but there are
aspects that kind of make me think they
don't know where wild lands went wrong
yeah the the first thing that struck me
immediately was the changer setting they
have shifted away from a real world
country and one that was none too
pleased with their characterization in
the previous game to a fictional island
that might as well be called a
biodiversity island it is just here's
here's all these different environments
that really don't exist in you know
combination in that small of a landmass
but we made it up anyway and also what
if there was a corporation there and
what if they were making drones and what
if those drones were supposed to be for
good but also for some reason they had
machine guns on them and then also what
if some evil soldiers came along and
took them over yeah the actual like
architecture of the island is look it
reminds me of the movie ex machina but
set in like a fictional New Zealand
there's a it's like an active volcano in
this game it's not a joke but then like
you said like across to another island
because it's an archipelago it's it's
like poppy fields yeah and then there's
absolute world and it's just it none of
that really fits together who cares it's
a video yeah it'll be fun to explore
right in most ways we can get to that
but they are changing a lot it seems
like they are going
much more toward the stealth side this
time around they still have like
vehicles and they said they are like
quick to say the vehicle handling is
improved because that was a minor
mechanical criticism the wildlands
but this time around it is like in the
presentation that they gave us which
felt a little bit cringy I'll admit
death stalks me but I survived yes so
you're the hunted this time for the
first time not the hunter which is cool
in theory because they showed you can go
prone and cover yourself in mud do like
prone takedowns but it's like this more
advanced paramilitary force hunting you
as opposed to the cartels right and
they're trying to and then also the
villain is Jon Bernthal from The
Punisher Fame yes he they just
introduced that like prequel DLC this
yeah look has they've been updating wild
lands you know for a long time and so
they've added this this add additional
little story campaign thing where he is
your associate in the ghosts and then
the the big he'll turn is that oh no
he's actually the leader of this illegal
paramilitary force that is what
something it not exactly clear what it
is that turned him evil but whatever the
case is he has a whole bunch of soldiers
with him and so he has taken over this
island I hope it's just like full-on ed
Harris he wants medals for all of his
Marines and that's why they're like
taking over this island I would it's
gotta be something along those lines it
feels like they're trying to paint him
as this very sort of like you know by
the books you know like total normal
soldier but then they just sort of like
okay but yeah now also he has this drone
army yeah so that's a big focus of this
- it's worth noting that as opposed to
wild lands when you played single-player
you still had three AI teammates and
saying artificial intelligence is pretty
generous because they were kind of dumb
yeah now if you play single-player they
want it to be more about survival in
isolation you will have three drones to
do the series a sync shot that it always
has but you'll be on your own unless you
have human teammates yes there are
character classes which doesn't
necessarily seem like it'll change too
much because you had all these loadouts
in the first game it'll just kind of
like in any Ubisoft or any game now
you'll have like perks abilities
etcetera like I was the Panther the
stealth one which let me like
instantaneously activate the smoke
grenade on my vest pretty helpful but
like outside that there's a marksman
they said they're only four when it
releases that didn't seem like it will
affect things too much what I am looking
forward to are the survival elements
they're kind of introducing right or at
least these bivouacs which kind of gave
me this Dragon's Dogma state of decay
vibe where you're prepping for an
expedition right before you head out and
you can either get you get weather
forecasts that like will give you a hint
on one to take missions on which I like
that I don't know if like you got to see
too much of that in the demo we pretty
much just saw that in the presentation
yeah they showed that in the
presentation when they dropped us into
the demo it was like midway through what
they showed the presentation so like it
was when they were attacking this one
drone factory to extract a scientist
that was there and you know presumably
was not on board with the whole
manufacturing of giant war machine kind
of thing so it was really just kind of
dropping into the action being like okay
pick your class alright let's start
let's start figuring out how to shoot
these dudes yeah then you can you can
like say in your weapons for accuracy
bonuses that also like not just keep
comparing to other games they reminded
me a monster hundred worlds how you can
it have like this meal before you go
there's injuries now they have to
actually treat
it'll just lower your max health and
tell you like bandage them etc it
definitely feels like they are starting
to pull a few others threads from other
open world innovations over the last few
years like you know they're obviously
not doing a very direct riff on stuff
like you know Monster Hunter or you know
Dark Souls but the camp and so all that
kind of stuff but it feels like they're
taking some ideas from those things and
like trying to figure out a way to
implement them into their weird military
shooter if they pull it off I also
really like the idea that you don't just
get a waypoint and go to it it seems
like they're kind of borrowing from
Assassin's Creed Odyssey which had that
mode that they recommended that would
like you you'd more naturally come
across missions which didn't always work
because you would get within the radius
and would say oh this is over here it
seems like this one they actively want
you to just kind of explore come across
missions if that ends up being the case
I will like that if they pulled that off
it might be
pretty like it it might make link the
exploration of a fundamental part right
the game as opposed to just this kind of
incidental thing you do I think you're
sort of more lukewarm than I am on the
actual like changes they're making yeah
I don't I I think they're they're smart
ideas for the most part it seems like
what they're talking about like makes
sense like adding the encampment
elements where you are sort of like
trying to build yourself up before you
go to these missions the the whole like
you know dropping a bunch of mud on
yourself like a predator style to sort
of like blend in which doesn't
completely blend in when you're actually
watching it it's like boy that sure is
just a big old backpack still sitting
out there but you know it looks like a
rifle to me yeah but I'm you know I'm a
guard I'm not that smart I'm not gonna
figure that out but and and also the the
traversal stuff they're talking about
doing with more of like the sliding down
the hills kind of the the making it much
harder to go up steep slopes I think all
that stuff is smart I think it's just
the demo they showed other than kind of
getting away from the premise which
really was my biggest problem with
wildlands like a lot of that game to me
one the characterizations were awful and
the way they tried to sort of thread the
needle of hey we're here fighting this
narco war and we're not gonna think too
hard about that basically taking the
premise of clear present danger and just
stripping the moral out of it like I was
super not into that and they seem to be
going further in the notion of more
narrative in this even though it's much
more like benign like hey here's a
generic evil military force that is not
aligned with any particular political
entity I just I think they maybe are
misunderstanding a little bit about what
people liked about wildlands in a sense
that it's sort of similar to something
like the division I feel like it's very
much a social hub game it is a game
where you and a few of your friends
mindlessly run around this world
shooting things driving things whatever
and you really aren't paying that but
close of attention to what's going on
the game and it feels like they're
trying to maybe go in a direction where
they're trying to make that much a more
interesting part of it but none of what
they showed to me at least was really
standing out in a way that made me think
yes I am really interested in this
narrative yeah so like I don't want to
talk too much about the presentation
because it was just like this just
behind closed doors thing that like
happens all the time but the trailer
itself is very much leaning into
Brotherhood and trauma it's in the title
break point it's how far someone has to
go before they just break down and stop
working and or give up and I'm not
convinced that not just Ubisoft because
again that's a whole conglomeration of
studios and all have different
identities and whatnot but UV soft Paris
wild lands did not what they didn't
characterize well dialogue was cringy
and any time they tried to say something
that I feel like they thought was
profound
about the drug trade and the ethics of
that and the ethics of a secret
paramilitary force going into someplace
and policing it right that's when I
disliked wildlands the most so for them
to say oh we're saying we're leaning
into narrative more this time around we
are the word realism was tossed around
three times and in Ghost Recon
presentations yeah that right away
raised red flags it's worth noting that
they have like a 14-year Green Beret
attached as a writer and military
adviser but it's also worth noting this
is nowhere near the first shooter
military game to have a military adviser
in fact almost everyone knows Call of
Duty has long as what's like I think
called duty for was the first like
modern warfare game to have a military
advisor and those games are as close as
you get to campy action blockbuster
totally just because you have a military
advisor does not mean it's going to be
authentic so when they start talking
about post-traumatic stress disorder
like a soldiers breaking point
Brotherhood realism when they if the
word realism is used in an open-world
Ubisoft game now I don't feel like they
understand completely what they're
trying to do yeah and I just you know
Jon Bernthal is a fine actor and you
know I think he will make a compelling
enough villain in this game like he
certainly has the intensity to sort of
sell that kind of thing but just the way
that they are sort of framing this as
like this they're kind of getting into
this notion of like you know
the tech industry as a sort of a
producer for you know the the various
war machines throughout the planet and
but it seems like they immediately are
veering away from even trying to address
that in a meaningful way by saying no
this tech company that owns this island
is producing these drones is
theoretically trying to do this for a
benevolent purpose but they have been
you know they've been taken over by
these soldiers who are doing their own
thing which again is not super clear at
this point and so it feels to me like
they're already trying to create a
little bit of a dodge to get out of the
way of even saying just a basic anything
about the idea of drone warfare or the
tech industry's role in you know the
American or any other war machine like
it just feels like no they've just
they've they've gone way out of their
way to make the set dressing as
explainable away as possible
yeah and I was when they first said it
was like a drone army I'm like okay well
actually I'd rather they do that than
have these Bolivians like like that
literally Bolivians that you're killing
but as then like as the trailer goes on
and I like the idea that you're fighting
it's a ghost who's also like
well-trained and it's not this cartel
but again I don't know that it was like
in some of the cutscenes we saw it is it
was like it in so many words it seemed
like a Tesla IFS corporation that's like
yeah we want to make the world a better
place we want to we want to remove
people from warfare and then it didn't
seem like they knew where they want to
go but again it was just like an early
preview totally I hope like I would love
for them to know it yeah I'm always
rooting for that based on Ubisoft Paris
history based on most video games in
general trying to reconcile this mayhem
that's unfolding around you and the fun
you're having with these serious stories
I could probably on one hand count the
games that actually did that well right
I'm holding out hope but I'm not betting
on them doing it well and if we're kind
of harping a little bit on this stuff
it's because what they gave us to go on
was not a lot you know like they spent a
long time talking about what they want
to do with this game and kind of setting
up the you know the the various new
features and kind of like the the
directional stuff they're doing with the
story the actual demo we played was like
15 minutes in fact I finished mine in
ten yeah like we got through it before
even the timer had got it ticked down
and what they played felt very much like
like wild lions you know like the
shooting has very very similar feel to
it whatever they've done with the class
systems and kind of the the you know
kind of building the loadouts and
whatever Lee it didn't feel radically
different from what wildlands was I
don't necessary expect it to because
it's you know two-year turnaround from
the last game a game they've been
updating regularly over that course of
that time but you know it's it still
feels like that shooter it is that game
where you and your friends will go in
and you will do these missions and
you'll be half paying attention while
you are just marking dudes and you're
like all right let's figure out our
strategy yeah for me personally it seems
like they're leaning in the direction I
wanted it to I I would actually I tried
to shy away from that I thought well
Linda that's worse when it was trying to
be a GTA style mayhem thing I've
actually enjoyed the tactile side and
I'd like that they're leaning into
stealth you can go down and bushes you
can go prone like you said yourself in
mud I like that and from our demo the
demo itself was I mean like promising
might be a bit generous just because we
only played 10 to 15 minutes but it
seems like on a design side on a
gameplay side they're going in the right
direction for me
but Doug Anne that doesn't change the
concern the large concerns and red flags
I have about the narrative that they are
you know decidedly admittedly trying to
focus on this yeah but I also wrote like
a more in-depth editorial on gamespot
about that if you want to go read that
we'll also have news coming out of that
all week I'm sure you guys will talking
about it the Beast cast etcetera thanks
everybody for joining and we'll see you
around
you